hello there reject nation we're gonna
watch the last of us to state of play
ps4 trailer or whatever this is it's a
23 minute video looking through the
comments I saw that there are so many
people who are requesting a reaction for
this this actually came out a few days
ago I so I know this is late but hey
we're here now
that's what matters this is different
alright there's a mood right there
I know you wish things are different but
they keep starting with that life
I was thankful different thing you know
what I'm excited to put I don't care I'm
excited to check this out
[Music]
I'm leading tomorrow do this smart
we believe in Jackson vulnerable do they
just get to get away with this
how'd you find us
[Music]
I'm ice love the mood in the dough is so
much
I really hope you make it
[Music]
[Music]
there's a cost
[Music]
who could have killed you maybe you
should have it all Charles I'm Neil
druckmann hi nails end of noggin the
director of the last of us part two
we're just a few weeks away from launch
on June 19th when the game will finally
be in your hands
the wait has been long and we're
extremely grateful for your patience
especially now in the midst of these
unprecedented and challenging times we
hope you're all taking care of
yourselves and that you your friends and
your loved ones are doing well because
of these extraordinary circumstances we
can't be together in this final stretch
and share the experience like we usually
would so today we're trying something
different okay something we've never
done before
all right I'm listening over the next 20
minutes or so we're going to give you an
in-depth look into what awaits you in
the last of us part two including new
details about the gameplay experience
and story and to cap it all off we'll be
showing a never-before-seen lengthy
gameplay sequence really you'll
definitely want to stick around for that
okay let me Adam here
[Laughter]
I'm supposed to take her to the
fireflies and walk away they were
actually gonna make a cure
the only catch never kill her The Last
of Us part two picks up Ellie and Joel
story several years after the events of
the first game Ellie and Joel have
settled in Jackson Wyoming amongst a
thriving community of survivors Cain
with the threats of the world kept
outside the town's walls Jackson has
been able to find relative peace and
even stability Ellie is now 19 was in
her own and has been able to forge
lasting relationships within the
community scale of one to ten
how would you rate our kiss from last
night it's snow gonna do that
however this piece is short-lived
Jackson and Ellie suffer a violent and
traumatizing event Allie sets up back
into the treacherous outside world in
search of retribution and justice her
journey will take her to new parts of
the country previously unexplored in the
Last of Us how beautiful that detail the
story spends multiple seasons and
climates from the snow-capped mountains
of Jackson to the Loess Pacific
Northwest
each introduces a wide range of exterior
interior environments for you to
navigate and explore rendered in
meticulous detail an unprecedented scale
with the lay Federation of the Naughty
Dog Engine our goal was to make these
environments not only beautiful but feel
is grounded and authentic to the cities
they're based on as possible I think you
have succeeded much of the story unfold
and what remains of Seattle a massive
former quarantine zone this locales are
incredibly diverse spanning a dense city
center with a skyline of towering high
rises to the beautiful suburbs and
stormy water fronts that surrounded the
city exhibits drastic shifts in
architecture elevation and weather a
chef I love rafty at new traversal
mechanics that afford greater
exploration and ways to navigate threats
Ellie is not only able to climb and jump
over gaps but she can use ropes to scale
vertical terrain or swing over obstacles
allowing you to discover new areas
resources and design narratives
these more open environments also create
new strategic considerations in combat
whether it's to get the jump on enemies
or bypassed an entire room where's the
vicodin
ever seen horseback riding will allow
Ellie to quickly cover some of these
expansive terrains that horse is gonna
dive suplement than a book is about
saying that's a leak just feel like it's
gonna happen however the world of the
Last of Us is as lush and inviting as it
is deadly Ezeli uncovers the path to
finding those who have wronged her she
must face the many threats of this
unknown city in the wake of the pandemic
and the fall of the quarantine zone
Seattle has become a warzone where two
warring factions find themselves in an
ongoing conflict for territory and
resources okay
one of these groups is the Washington
Liberation Front otherwise known as the
W LM okay the W LF our militia group
that began as resistance to the military
occupation of Seattle and eventually rel
control the city from them they are
highly trained organized and well
equipped with weapons they stole from
the Army they occupy much of the city
imprisoning or killing trespassers on
sight on the other side of this bloody
conflict is a group of religious zealots
called the Sara fights or scars defined
by the self inflicted deep cuts that
they bear across their faces like the W
left they're deeply tribalistic
and territorial they're known for being
stealthy using overgrowth as cover and
they use more silent weapons like bows
and arrows clip your wings
[Music]
beyond this conflict among survivors the
threat that originally brought the world
to its knees is very much present every
human is in danger of falling victim to
the infected
there's defected runners for more
numerous and aggressive in this game the
blind but extremely deadly clickers and
the stalkers who sneak and hide until
they're ready to attack surprise extreme
agility and brutal violence I I suck it
laughs eating more - there's new stages
of infected such as the shamblers large
heavily armored enemies that are covered
in pustules upon getting close to you
they expel a corrosive spork louder but
burns its victims where our most
terrifying and lethal new forms of
infected we'll have to wait until you
play the game for yourself with the
sound effects will consideration of how
you approach every combat encounter and
how you leverage Ellie's unique skills
equipment and environment to your
advantage something the WLF patrolled
the streets of Seattle with guard dogs
which are capable of detecting and
following you
even while uncover oh I can pick up your
scent and alert their handlers to your
presence oh listen mode will reveal your
scent trail so keep moving and cause
distractions to avoid detection oh man
that's 25 years after the pandemic again
I'm gonna suck up and do the overgrow
element use tall grass to hide from
enemies and go prone to stay out of
sight however this form of analogue
stealthy means you're never fully hidden
if enemies get close enough they can
discover you even ingress of course when
Ellie is overwhelmed running away is a
viable option
you can also break glass or crawl
through tight spaces away to find new
paths or areas to evade or take on your
enemies in any given combat situation
you can flee an encounter and
re-establish stealth to regain the
advantage if you absolutely have to
fight your way out there are a variety
of tools at your disposal at least more
agile than most of her enemies she could
sprint and quickly dodge incoming
attacks learning how opponents attack
with different weapons and mastering the
timing of her dodges will prevent you
from taking them and spin create
opportunities to counter-attack you can
use throw book items a well-placed job
to stun enemies yeah or using them as a
after so or buy some time to figure out
the next move I love all the dialog in
between oh my god allies will take part
and help you navigate the environments
spot enemies and meaningfully help you
in combat in town
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
between the human survivors and the
roaming infected there will be times
where multiple threats are present
creating new strategic considerations
and opportunities you can choose where
to attack these opponents separately and
directly or find ways to pit them
against each other
oh that's smart that's realistic right
or wait until their numbers have thinned
out and engage with whoever's left
to be brutal running headstrong or just
pit them against each other that's me
[Music]
attention details crazy
coupled with deep systems that give you
greater control and influence a weird
journey can you read the whole magazine
as you play you'll be able to invest in
the broad collection of crafting items
weapon and Clair upgrades through
training manuals scattered throughout
the environment and scavenging for
ingredients these skills and upgrade
manuals care to a variety of play styles
and the choices you make will create
your own distinct experience we also
wanted to extend that agency in
personalization to your weapons to our
new workbench systems scavenger parts to
modify and improve your weapons
performance and attributes all of which
are visualized and become part of your
character
survival will also require using the
parts and ingredients that you'll find
an environment which can often into a
wide rim an offensive and defensive item
I don't want to have a shooting guard
dog though explosive arrows pistol
suppressors and more do it
[Music]
all of these gameplay systems are meant
to immerse you in the world and make you
feel and lockstep with Ellie's emotional
journey yeah of course I mean I was I
was just saying like even in the
gameplay of just what we're teasing you
can still feel the cinematic of them as
we've said before the epitome this is
nine dogs largest the most ambitious
team it may seem like we cover a lot but
we only scratch the surface of what it's
like to play the Last of Us party we
can't wait for you to experience it all
for yourself until then here's an
extended sequence of never-before-seen
game deck enjoy
[Music]
which is supposed to be like eight
minutes long or something
did you find
hmm it's interesting how the camera
doesn't go down it doesn't cut into the
water instead on our efforts like that
in the last game to be honest as knows
most games would like follow the camera
within and this does like a cut
[Music]
damn how does your bow and arrow not
give like ruin with all that water
damage I'm no Archer I don't know
it's at a sunny part of placement Oh
[Music]
lucky you
I heard that Isaac wants us to retake
all of downtown no way not after what
went down last time
even Isaac isn't that crazy I heard
[Music]
you know she keeps giving you guys heads
up and he he forcing her to kill you
guys
[Music]
this is like one of those rare games
where I could just watch like the game
playing and like not even play poor
doggie but I bet when I'm playing I'm
gonna try to murder all those dogs
because you know they're gonna get me in
trouble
[Music]
just like that man these are just the
humans this is not even the infected
characters oh yeah
[Music]
wowie
[Music]
sigh cockroach and here the other day
you Nora
diehard
we hear I'm stupid you're gonna tell us
where she went when Isaac talks to us
about this I'm getting tired of this
Nora Nora I'm not going down for her man
I mean
[Music]
you remember me
[Music]
I can't believe it's finally coming
there's been nothing bad that's happened
along the way I was beautiful
beautiful so excited can't wait to see
if I'm disappointed by story element
parts or if I'm really happy with
overall execution alright guys well just
to make clear I'm not gonna talk about
any of the leaks in this discussion I'm
just gonna strictly talk about more of
what was teased here what was shown here
I'm still very excited for the game the
mood the tone the real lived in
experience it seems like that's like the
main thing they wanted to go for in
developing this game was to make it feel
as not just like he said here not just
beautiful but also grounded and as close
to reality as possible I do find it kind
of ironic you know you hear words
pandemic and stuff like that in here in
the in the world of the Last of Us while
we're going through like a real-life
pandemic not as bad days I mean it's
it's bad in real life but it's not as
you know bad as like having things like
runners and clickers existing in the
world today bit of irony that one of the
most anticipated games of all time and
now like a very controversial game
coming out during this time in the world
but what we're seeing here I love all
the enhancements of all the stealth
abilities and then the enhancements of
danger that they've brought to the
gameplay which makes it all the more
intense so it's like while you're
getting enhancements I'm being able to
do stealth it also makes it a little bit
harder sneak around like when you're
trying to avoid the dog so you can pick
up on your scent things like that
because that was kind of one of my
quarrels like with Metal Gear Solid
because they did Metal Gear Solid for
PlayStation which didn't have as much in
play abilities as when they did Metal
Gear Solid 2 and then rereleased Metal
Gear Solid 1 on GameCube but you were
able to do all the gameplay maneuver so
you can do a Metal Gear 2 so it made
playing Metal Gear Solid that much
easier because it didn't really enhance
the danger threat level of your enemies
in the video game or as here they're
increasing that they're even saying like
the runners have other they come at you
a lot more aggressive and in higher
numbers so while you can do a little bit
more the challenges will still be
equally matched which is something I'm
very much
excited for weather gonna do like the
gameplay the mechanics the graphics
everything involved that was a PS Vita
was it that was a Pia I'm just now
realizing that that lactation girl who
he'll he stabbed in the throat then I
just got a flash in my head of the this
because I love those details that you
see in movies and you kill a character
who's listening to a song or whatever
I'm like a ipod or something and then
when it falls over the the song is still
playing and they just flash them ahead
yeah why tough Vita I don't know getting
too hung up on it out this is taking
place in the future of the PSP who still
survived I think I'm not looking forward
to are the the animal deaths granted I'm
a big fan of the Red Dead games I know
you gotta kill plenty of animals there
that moment where they the dog gets set
on fire and you hear a whimpering that
just is something so heartbreaking I
appreciate all the realism this game is
going for man thoughts a little bit
haunting and you just know that horse is
definitely gonna die at some point it
looks cool right around on and
everything but you just know it's gonna
die I love the tease that they're giving
of a new kind of next-level infected
monster that you're gonna have to go up
against all you do is hear the sound
effects of it honestly I suck at beating
anything past a runner even a runner I
have a hard time with a flicker stalker
and all those that there that are very
very difficult for me to beat I just
know that whatever new monster they have
in store is just gonna be a pain in my
ass I'm gonna be getting very mad I can
also imagine while watching a gameplay
like this that it can be frustrating for
some people because this is more along
the lines of how I'd probably play The
Last of Us on my own time but there's
people who are much more completionist
who want to look around and want to pick
up everything around them like when my
girlfriend Olivia is watching me over my
shoulder if I'm just trying to move the
plot forward and move to the VIX or
something she gets very irritated to me
because she's one of those people and I
know there's a lot of you guys out there
who like I got it explore every little
opening and pick up as much as I
possibly can and take the time to
upgrade for a gameplay trailer you're
gonna want to keep all the cool stuff in
here so you're not gonna get all that
the word that keeps coming back to mine
when watching this is lived-in
like even the little bits of dialogue
that you get in between or holding
people up all the swear words that are
happening the banter back and forth all
the dialogue feels very natural I bet
that with every single to ever you like
Dinah you have to redo beating some of
these bad guys again the dialogue will
perhaps even change up here and there
and then what they're talking about with
these two main territorial groups with
the WLF I think they said Sarah fights
ser scars for another nickname for them
or something I love the contrast between
that WLF seems a lot more what like the
kind of groups that we might have seen
in the first last of us and then the
scars they seem very tribal and their
methods seem a lot more savage you know
it's always way more brutal with like
cutting people up and using bows and
arrows things that slice into you as
opposed to you know gunshot wounds
anytime I see footage of them they earth
me it scares the crap out of me I played
though The Last of Us only one time a
couple of years ago so there's some
details I'm missing I feel like I'm
probably gonna end up watching one of
those cinematic cutscenes compilations
just so I'm like really truly refresh
and everything is I don't have time to
play the whole game all over again
there's something in my brain that's
telling me Ellie couldn't swim in the
first game but here she's clearly
swimming and she's great at it yeah
she's grown-up she can do it now I'm not
gonna talk about any of the leaks all
right now what I'll say to acknowledge
that though is if you happen to have
heard the leaks and if you had a
negative response to certain plot things
that you heard happen in the game I
would say still give it a chance with
almost anything that decides to be bold
or ambitious or take their story in a
new direction that I've seen at least in
the movie sphere or TV sphere sometimes
I mean when when it does happen if
people get really mad and they don't
like the different take or direction or
the subversion of expectation that
happened and then sometimes with good
execution people can love the way it
developed and how surprising it was the
analogy I'll use for that just off the
top of my head would and this is in no
way implying any actual thing that
occurs in the Last of Us do I'm just
making that clear a subversion of
expectation
way they handle the last Jedi that
didn't go down so well with so much of
the fandom right whereas opposed to like
there's the movie Avengers end game
where something happens with Thanos in
the first like 10 minutes of the movie
that totally surprised people but people
for the most part seem to really love
that movie that I remember every time I
watch in the theaters you're like oh
that's like what they do with Thanos in
the first 10 minutes especially with
endgame if you look at what happened in
the first 10 minutes there if that
leaked people would probably be really
upset about that leak and would have
been like I can't believe they did that
they're ruining Marvel MCU or trying to
subvert expectations I'm not saying that
with whatever you guys might have heard
with the last of us if altum Utley by
playing it you'll be like all right
never mind even though I heard the leaks
and then they kind of upset me now that
I'm actually able to play it I like it
I'm not saying that will ultimately be
the outcome for everyone or the majority
I really have no idea I might fall into
the camp of not liking the way the plot
unfolds ultimately I would say though
especially when you watch it a state of
play trailer like this give the game a
chance just for the gameplay and
mechanics alone that they and the labor
of love that went into developing and
crafting this just give it a chance you
know if you end up not like you know
sorry hey it's worth a shot that's
that's where that's where I stand right
now all right guys what would you think
of the state of play trailer leave your
thoughts down below subscribe to the
reel rejects click that notification
bell can't wait for this game see you
guys soon